>> Tucker: LAST NIGHT’S
DEMOCRATIC FORUM ON CBS WASN’T
THE FINAL PRIMARY DEBATE OF THE
SEASON BUT LIKELY THE LAST ONE
THAT WILL MATTER BETWEEN TONIGHT
AND THE NEXT DEBATE, A TOTAL OF
21 STATES AND THAT INCLUDES
CALIFORNIA AND TEXAS, WILL HOLD
THEIR PRIMARIES.
BY THEN IT WAS ALMOST CERTAINLY
BE OVER.
SO YOU THINK THE CANDIDATES
WOULD USE THE TIME TO TALK ABOUT
THINGS THAT VOTERS CARED DEEPLY
ABOUT AND FOR A BRIEF MOMENT,
ONE DID THAT.
IN HIS FIRST ANSWER, BERNIE
SANDERS BROUGHT UP WAGES.
HE SAID THEY OUGHT TO RISE
FASTER, WHICH IS TRUE.
HOW COULD THEY GO UP WITH THE
OPEN BORDERS HE’S DEMANDING IS
UNANSWERABLE.
BUT AT LEASE HE ANSWERED IT.
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG IS NOT THE
FRONTRUNNER.
HE WOULD LIKE TO BE.
WHEN GIVEN HIS CHANCE TO SPEAK,
HE WENT TO THE ISSUE HE BELIEVES
VOTERS CARE ABOUT MOST.
THE FACT THAT BERNIE SANDERS IS
A SECRET RUSSIAN AGENT.
>> VLADIMIR PUTIN THINKS THAT
DONALD TRUMP SHOULD BE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES AND THAT’S
WHY RUSSIA IS HELPING YOU GET
ELECTED SO YOU LOSE TO HIM.
>> Tucker: SO THAT’S WHAT
BLOOMBERG’S CONSULTANTS TOLD HIM
TO SAY.
LESSONS HERE, DUMB PEOPLE GET
RICH.
ONE AUDIENCE WAS POWERLIFUL
MOVED BY BLOOMBERG’S ATTACK, THE
OTHER CANDIDATES.
AT THE MENTION OF VLADIMIR
PUTIN, THE STAGE ERUPTED.
IT SOUNDED LIKE A RADICAL BOOK
CLUB FROM THE 70s.
OLD PEOPLE YELLING ABOUT THE
COLD WAR.
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA!
PETE BUTTIGIEG IS 38 BUT SEEMS A
CENTURY OLDER, JUMPED IN WITH
HIS THEORY WHAT TRUMP AND HIS
PUPPET MATTER WANT IS POLITICAL
CHAOS.
BUTTIGIEG SEEMS TOTALLY
CONVINCED THAT NOBODY EVER SAID
THAT BEFORE.
BY THIS POINT, THE MODERATORS ON
CBS GAVE UP.
THE CHAOS PUTIN HOPED FOR
DESCENDED ON THE DEBATE STAGE.
AND THEN SANDERS ATTACKED
AMERICA, A COUNTRY HE HATES.
HERE HE IS EXPLAINING THE
AMERICAN CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
IS ACTUALLY MORE REPRESSIVE THAN
COMMUNIST CHINA’S.
>> WE HAVE A CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM TODAY THAT IS NOT ONLY
BROKEN, IT’S RACIST, GOT MORE
PEOPLE IN JAIL THAN ANY OTHER
COUNTRY ON EARTH INCLUDING
CHINA.
ONE OF THE REASONS FOR THAT IS A
HORRIFIC WAR ON DRUGS.
>> Tucker: OH, THE WAR ON DRUGS!
BERNIE SANDERS TALKS ABOUT THAT
IN EVERY SPEECH HE GIVES.
A DECLINING COUNTRY WITH A SAD
UNDEREMPLOYED MIDDLE CLASS
OBVIOUSLY NEEDS TO SMOKE A TON
MORE WEED.
THAT’S BERNIE’S SOLUTION.
FIRE UP A BOWL.
NUMB OUT.
MAYBE YOU WON’T NOTICE.
SO WHERE IS THIS WEED GOING TO
COME FROM?
BERNIE HAS A PLAN FOR THAT, TOO.
BLACK PEOPLE WILL SELL IT TO
YOU.
NO KID SOMETHING WATCH THIS.
>> I’LL TELL YOU WHAT ELSE WE’RE
GOING TO DO.
WE’RE GOING TO PROVIDE HELP TO
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN LATINO
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY TO
START BUSINESSES TO SELL LEGAL
MARIJUANA RATHER THAN LET A FEW
CORPORATIONS CONTROL THE
LEGALIZED MARIJUANA MARKET.
>> Tucker: THAT’S A REAL CLIP,
BY THE WAY.
SO FIRST THEY FILL BLACK
NEIGHBORHOODS WITH ABORTION
CLINICS.
NOW THE FRONTRUNNER IS
ENCOURAGING MORE BLACK KIDS TO
SILL DRUGS, THIS IS THE PARTY
THAT LOVES BLACK AMERICA.
DOESN’T SOUND LIKE IT.
WHATEVER.
JOE BIDEN CHANGED THE SUBJECT BY
MAKING LOUD NOISES.
BIDEN HAS LOST HIS ABILITY TO
SPEAK CLEARLY.
THAT’S GOT TO BE FRUSTRATING FOR
ANYONE.
IN BIDEN’S CASE, IT HAS LED TO A
SERIES OF RAGE ERUPTIONS.
>> BERNIE HASN’T PASSED MUCH OF
ANYTHING.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS -- NO,
NO, NO.
>> I GET TO ANSWER THAT.
>> THE FACT IS --
>> YOU’RE OUT OF TIME.
>> I’M NOT OUT OF TIME.
YOU SPOKE OVER TIME AND I’M
GOING TO TALK.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS, LOOK
AT WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE.
LOOK WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE.
>> Tucker: THE CROWD ROARED
BECAUSE SCREAMING ALWAYS ELICITS
ROARS FROM CROWDS.
OUR ANIMAL BRAINS AT WORK.
THOSE TRYING TO FOLLOW WHAT
BIDEN WAS SAYING, DEAF PEOPLE
READING ON CLOSED CAPTION, IT
WAS A PROFOUNDLY CONFUSING
MOMENT.
BIDEN HOPPED THE TRACKS AND
BECAME A FIERY DERAILMENT
PLUNKING OFF THE BRIDGE TO A
GORGE BELOW.
>> I MAKE IT TO CLEAR TO CHINA,
WE’RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO MOVE
CLOSER TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
IN FACT PREVENT CHINA -- PREVENT
NORTH KOREA FROM LAUNCHING
MISSILES, TO TAKE THEM DOWN AND
IF WE DON’T -- WHY AM I
STOPPING?
NOBODY ELSE STOPS.
>> OKAY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Tucker: WHY AM I STOPPING, HE
ASKED?
BECAUSE DISJOINTED SENTENCE
FRAGMENTS ARE PRODUCTIVE.
A FEW MONTHS OF NOW, HE WILL BE
RECITING ALAN GINSBERG POEMS AT
BUS STOPS.
AND ELIZABETH WARREN WON’T BE
PRESIDENT.
SHE’S VERY UNPLEASANT.
YOU’LL BE IN PARAGUAY BY THE END
OF THE FIRST ELIZABETH WARREN
ADMINISTRATION JUST TO STOP THE
NOISE.
SHE CAN TELL SHE’S DOOMED.
SHE’S NOT STUPID.
SHE DECIDED TO SPEND HER
REMAINING TIME DESTROYING
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG.
THAT’S A NICE WAY TO GO OUT IF
YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
IT’S A SERVICE TO THE COUNTRY.
LAST TIME IT DIDN’T WORK.
INSTEAD WARREN JUST HUMILIATED
HERSELF.
>> I WAS VISIBLY PREGNANT.
THE PRINCIPAL WISHED ME LUCK AND
GAVE MY JOB TO SOMEONE ELSE.
PREGNANCY DISCRIMINATION, YOU
BET.
I WAS 21 YEARS OLD.
I DIDN’T HAVE A UNION TO PROTECT
HIM AND I DIDN’T HAVE FEDERAL
LAW ON MY SIDE.
I PACKED UP MY STUFF AND I WENT
HOME.
AT LEAST I DIDN’T HAVE A BOSS
THAT SAID TO ME, KILL IT!
THE WAY THAT MAYOR BLOOMBERG --
>> I NEVER SAID THAT.
>> -- SAID TO ONE OF HIS
PREGNANT EMPLOYEES.
>> Tucker: WHOA, WAIT A SECOND.
WE HAVE NEWS EMERGING.
DID YOU JUST HEAR ELIZABETH
WARREN SAY THERE ARE
CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH
ENCOURAGING ABORTION MIGHT BE
WRONG?
WHOA!
DON’T TELL PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
SHE WILL LOSE HER FUNDING.
WARREN’S STORY ABOUT HER OWN
PREGNANCY COULD HAVE BEEN THE
MOST DEPRESSING.
THE STORY IS A LIE.
IT’S BEEN DEBUNKED BY HER ON
TAPE.
BUT WARREN KEEPS TELLING THE
STORY WITH EXACTLY THE SAME
INFLECTIONS AND PAUSES AND HAND
GESTURES.
KEEP IN MIND, THIS IS A PERSON
THAT WAS ONCE A TENURED HARVARD
LAW PROFESSOR.
SHE GENUINELY HAD A GOOD BOOK AT
ONE POINT.
PEOPLE RESPECTED HER.
NOW?
NOW WARREN IS DEGRADING HER SOME
WITH SOME TRANSPARENT WHOPPER TO
SHOW YOU HOW OPPRESSED SHE IS.
BY THE TIME THIS IS OVER, SHE
WILL BE HILLARY CLINTON.
PACING HER BACK YARD WITH A
BOTTLE OF WINE AND SENDING
BITTER TWEETS ABOUT TRUMP AT
MIDNIGHT.
IT’S PATHETIC AND SAD.
IT’S UNIVERSAL THIS YEAR.
EVERYONE IN THE DEMOCRATIC FIELD
HAS BEEN GREATLY DIMINISHED BY
THIS.
IT’S NOT BECAUSE THEY’RE ALL BAD